لا يفوت الحاج ابو خالد التجمع السنوي
لفلسطيني اوروبا وككل مره يستحب معه
الابناء والاحفاده لتورثهم رايه العوده
ولتبقى ارض الاجداد محفوره في ذاكرتهم لا
يمحوها البعد عن الوطن ورغم تقدمه في
العمر لا تزال ذاكره ابو خالد تختزن كثيرا
من المشاهد التي تلخص رحله التهجير القصري
للفلسطينيين من بيوتهم وقراهم شو بتعني
لفلسطين غير اني انا منتظر
في ارض فلسطين ولا انسى حق العوده في اي
ساعه من ساعات حتى اعلم في الليل اني انا
موجود في في بلدنا
[تصفيق]
التمسك بحق العوده وتعلق فلسطينيه الشتات
بوطنهم من ابرز الرسائل التي تضمنتها
فعاليات المؤتمر مؤتمر يراد له ان يكون
مظله لفلسطينيه اوروبا وهدفه تعزيز دورهم
وقوتهم في الدفاع عن حقوقهم خصوصا مع
تزايد الضغوط والتضييق في الغرب على
الانشطه السياسيه المؤيده للشعب الفلسطيني
في كل الاخطار الاوروبيه هناك مؤسسات
فلسطينيه تعمل ضمن القوانين الاوروبيه
ولها تخفي ان تعبر عن ما تراه من تمسك
بهذه الحقوق وسيستمر العمل الفلسطيني رغم
كل هذه التحديات وبالمناسبه هذه التحديات
تتصاعد ولكنها ليست جديده
لم يتوقف الفلسطينيون عن حمل قضيتهم الى
العالم فهذا معرض لبعض المستندات والكتب
التاريخيه والوثائق التي تدل على الهويه
الفلسطينيه متحف خرايط
نسبه انه فلسطين موجوده لانه بالمدارس
السويديه وبالجامعات السويديه دائما
بفرجوا الخرائط الاسرائيليه الموجوده
اليوم بس بخفوا عن الجيل هذا انه في خرائط
فلسطينيه من قبل الاحتلال استذكاره
فلسطينيه اوروبا لنكبه خلال مؤتمرهم
السنوي يؤكدوا ان الجرح غائر لم يلتئم بعد
وان احيائها في الظرف الحالي هو وجه من
اوجه النضال الشعبي كي لا تظل القضيه
الفلسطينيه غائبه ام مغيبه عن الادراك
الدولي نور الدين بوزيان الجزيره من مدينه
مالمو السويد